Um,
today we're going to be talking about loyalists.
And in doing so we're going to be talking about the range of responses to the
building crisis in British America.
So basically over the course of the first few lectures here,
we've looked at the logic behind some British policy.
We've looked at the logic of resistance.
Now we're seeing a little momentum of resistance building up.
So now also we need to look at people who maybe are not as eager to resist
against the British government.
And these are the loyalist.
Um,
and it's going to seem sort of opposite as to what I ought to be doing at this
moment.
But before we launch into looking at the loyalists,
I actually want to go back for a moment to the first continental congress.
Partly because,
as you'll hear when I'm talking about it,
it's actually the debates and proceedings and an outcome of this first
continental congress that really helps crystallize matters.
Because as we'll see,
it really is 1774,
1775 where you begin to have people who kind of identify themselves as
loyalists.
And partly because,
as you'll see,
even in the first continental congress itself,
there actually were a range of opinions.
Not Everybody in the congress agreed on the level of what needed to be done.
So it's not as though in 1774 you had a blob of patriot and a blob of loyalists.
You had a spectrum of opinions throughout society.
So let's look first at the first continental congress in a little bit more
detail here just at the start of electric.
And as I mentioned when I last discussed the congress,
it wasn't only composed of radicals though,
as I'll discuss in a moment,
just the simple fact that this congress was called was a pretty bold action.
But even so,
there was a range of opinions represented in the Congress.
So there were some more radical types present.
So you did have people like Samuel Adams and Patrick Henry there,
and already these people are radical in their thoughts.
They're already pondering the possibility of worry.
You'll hear from Patrick Henry in a moment,
but there were also moderates there who were more in favor of reconciliation or
reform and who hoped that the meeting of the congress would maybe show
parliament that the colonies were United and determined and that maybe the
simple fact that it met would inspire parliament to modify some of its policies.
And as we'll see,
it ends up being that those who were more radical in their leanings ultimately
have a slight majority in this continental congress.
And so in the end they actually win the day.
But it isn't obvious that that's going to be the case at the outset.
Now that the delegates to this congress met in Philadelphia in the beginning of
September in 1774 there were 50 men present and as I mentioned before,
most of them had some kind of experience with politics in their individual
colonies.
Now if you do think about the fact that this congress existed,
just calling it into existence was something of a radical act.
Because if you think about it,
this is a colonial congress,
a self appointed Congress that granted itself power of some kind over all of the
colonies.
And even as we're about to see past something that was in the equivalent of
legislation that applied to all of the colonies.
So in a sense that's a pretty radical gesture.
And I found actually a satire written in 1774 that does a good job,
I think of showing how the congress did seem radical to some and,
and how to sum it,
did not represent happy,
good things that we're about to happen,
but actually represented something frightening and out of control.
And it's actually,
it's a broad side.
So it was a single sheet.
Um,
and this is a satire.
So it was meant to be making fun of people who were just elected to the
continental cron.
Congress is actually from New York.
And it came out just after New York had decided who was going to go to the
continental Congress from New York.
So these were people who were just making fun of the whole idea of having a
continental congress.
So it's a broad side and it's,
it's made to look like a very formal series of resolutions and actually it's
titled a meeting of the true sons of liberty.
Um,
and I met after class,
I'll post a link to it.
It's actually as is everything these days digitized so that you can actually see
what it looks like.
So the broad side series of resolutions,
it reads number one,
resolved that in this general time of resolving,
we have as good a right to resolve is the most resolute.
Okay.
This is not a serious series of resolutions.
Number two,
resolved that we have the whole sense of the city,
county,
province and all the colonies concentrated in our own persons.
Again,
something that's not really the people writing these resolutions.
Number three,
resolved that these resolves and any we may afterwards see fit to promulgate
shall be approved by all sensible and Goodman and our parent country and that
they shall even make that ungracious Barlett Lord North Violet is one of those
words you don't get to save very often.
It made me really happy to type it today that ungracious Barlett Lord North.
It will make him shake in his shoes when he sees them and split his breeches.
Okay.
The eternal joke of people splitting your pants like that dates back to 1774 and
practically earlier,
I would assume it goes earlier than that,
the eternal joke.
So Lord North's,
we'll shake it,
his shoes,
it will make him split his breeches resolved number for that any act or acts of
parliament would prevent the colonies from triumphing over the liberties
sporting with the goods or at will claiming the properties of the British
ministry is a cruel oppression in which all the colonies are intimately
concerned.
Resolved that the nonpayment of debt contracted with England is the only way to
save the credit of those who have no money to pay their debts with.
Okay.
So that's attacking the logic of people who don't want to pay taxes,
but they just don't have money and they don't feel like pain resolved.
That the best way of approved,
of approving our loyalty is to spit in the king's face as the means of opening
his eyes.
Okay.
And then finally,
lastly resolved that every man,
woman,
or child who does not agree with our sentiments,
whether he,
she or they understand them or not is an enemy to his country where soever he
was born,
whatever he may think of it and that he ought at least to be tarred and
feathered if not hanged,
drawn and quartered.
All statutes,
laws and ordinances whatsoever to the contrary,
not withstanding.
Okay.
So that's,
that tire clearly throws within it a slew of accusations against this pending
continental congress.
You can see that it's being accused of being arbitrary,
of promoting lawlessness,
of having a lack of tolerance for anybody who feels any differently,
that it's being accused of displaying a lack of respect or gratitude towards the
mother country,
maybe even vindictiveness.
And as it was clear in that first we resolve to be resolving in this time of
resolving their,
also accusing it of having like a stupid amount of self importance,
right?
Continental Congress harrumph sure.
Go have your little continental congress.
So any of these reasons would have been part of the reasoning why someone might
have felt that this continental congress was not only not a good idea,
but potentially a dangerous idea.
So for one reason or another,
people clearly found the calling of the continental congress.
Somewhat remarkable.
So the congress is,
first meeting was on September 5th and one of the first things that they had to
debate logically enough is how the congress is going to vote on issues.
Should voting be based on the population of each colony,
which obviously gives bigger colonies an advantage or should each county have
one vote?
The eternal question,
obviously this is going to come back and hit us with a vengeance at the
constitutional convention.
How they,
oh,
that's one of those question and a question of questions that I have not gone to
look at the record to see formerly how they voted on the voting.
I would assume they voted by person,
but I will have to actually look that up to tell you how they voted.
The question was how do you vote on how you're going to vote?
That's a really good question.
I will,
I will come in next time.
Um,
and tell you the answer to that question.
I had not considered that before.
Okay.
How do you vote on voting?
Um,
okay.
So however you vote on voting,
um,
that was one of the first things that they had to debate was how voting was
going to work.
And as I said,
it's going to come back and smack us again in the constitutional convention.
Now,
this whole debate voting on voting,
um,
tried the patience of Patrick Henry.
Okay.
Patrick Henry,
obviously one of the more radical members of this first continental congress,
really impatient at the idea that they're dilly dallying about voting and how to
calculate population of different colonies.
So this is what Henry said in a burst of frustration.
Government is dissolved.
We are in a state of nature,
sir.
The distinctions between Virginians,
Pennsylvania New Yorkers and new Englanders are no more.
I am not a Virginian but an American.
Clearly he has a real talent for the bold statement,
the memorable bold statement.
I am not a Virginia and button America and kind of not as famous as the liberty
or death thing,
but still clearly really bold.
Also clearly referring to the logic John Locke social contract.
He's by saying that we're in a state of nature,
Henry's basically saying that the social contract between the colonies and the
crown has been broken.
Clearly he's one of the more radical members of Congress.
So everybody didn't hear what he said and stand up and applaud in lineup.
Yes,
we're in a state of nature go.
He's an extreme.
But in fact you can see throughout the continental congress tension between a
real spectrum of opinions.
There were militant members really promoting resistance,
even already kind of thinking maybe wars on the horizon and then they were more
moderate members promoting reconciliation or maybe reform of some kind.
And you can see the push of the more militant members and the sort of debate
between the different kinds of opinions almost immediately within the first few
weeks of meeting with the arrival of what came to be called the Suffolk Resolves
Suffolk,
Massachusetts,
and again,
obviously Suffolk,
Massachusetts,
not surprisingly,
these what you will see as being very bold resolutions originate in
Massachusetts,
but they were not introduced by Massachusetts delegates.
This is something John Adams does later too.
Like because Massachusetts is such a radical colony,
people delegates from Massachusetts know that they had better not be the ones to
promote anything.
That sounds radical because everybody will immediately dismiss it.
So in this case,
the Massachusetts delegates,
no,
if they come forward and say we brought these resolved,
you want you to consider them,
people would probably assume that they were too extreme.
But if they appear to come from Massachusetts to the continental congress,
well then that becomes something that people will be more open to considering.
So this set of resolves was sent to the Congress,
supposedly from Suffolk County,
Massachusetts,
which is I Guess Boston's county.
And they became known as the Suffolk resolves.
So here's a list of some of the things that these declared,
okay.
Number one,
they declared the intolerable acts or the coercive acts,
however you want to refer to them as being unconstitutional and not to be
obeyed.
Number two,
they said that Massachusetts,
which you remember that their government had been dissolved,
things had been changed because of all everything that's been going on in
Boston.
Massachusetts should create a new assembly for itself to collect all colonial
taxes and withhold them from the crown until the Massachusetts government had
been restored to its constitutional foundation.
Number three,
the resolves advise people to arm themselves and formed their own militia in
preparation for resisting the possibility of British attack.
Number four,
they propose that the jailing of any Patriot leader gave people the right to
jail British officials,
and then finally they recommended stringent economic sanctions against Britain.
Okay.
Clearly those are really radical resolutions on a bunch of levels.
Now,
they were proposed,
they were red.
They were presented some in the continental Congress applauded them,
but they were not initially acted on for obvious reasons because they made a lot
of delegates,
extremely nervous as delegate.
Joseph Galloway of Pennsylvania said the Suffolk resolves quote contained a
complete declaration of war against Great Britain.
Okay.
They seem pretty extreme.
Galloway was typical of many who felt that just failing to recognize,
recognize parliaments,
right to regulate trade,
didn't accomplish anything.
And as a matter of fact,
he wasn't even sure that that was right in theory.
So Galloway at this moment came up with his own suggestion about the best course
of action.
And although in comparison with the really radical Suffolk results,
his suggestions are going to sound conservative.
He actually are promoting ideas that in and of themselves,
as you'll hear our radical.
So basically Galloway tries to come up with a way to change the basis of the
relationship between the American colonies and the mother country.
And so he suggest,
suggest a new plan of union that he thinks are going to,
it's going to settle the whole matter.
So Galloways plan of union suggested forming a separate American legislature,
he called it,
I think the grand council,
and it would be elected by colonial assemblies and individual colonies would
continue to govern their own internal affairs and the grand counsel would
regulate commercial,
civil and criminal matters that affected the colonies generally as a whole.
Now according to Galloways plan,
this grand council could veto parliamentary legislation.
Clearly that's a pretty bold gesture,
but still it would be inferior to parliament,
which could still initiate legislation relevant to the colonies.
In essence,
the grand council would be kind of an inferior branch of the British parliament.
And the great principle behind Galloways plan was quote,
that no law should bind America without her consent.
So that's really what he's trying to do here is devise a way for the colonists
to consent to what's being passed in parliament.
Now,
interestingly,
the vote over Galloways plan of union was close,
but it was ultimately defeated.
And I suppose looking back in the long view of time,
it probably wasn't likely that the British government would have approved of the
creation of a kind of second colonial parliament.
And as we'll see,
that's unlikely,
particularly when you look later at how parliament responded to these
continental congresses.
And in a sense you could say the continental congress was a sort of temporary
version of a grand council.
So the fact that parliament wasn't too keen on that would suggest they wouldn't
be very excited about a little baby colonial parliament branch of parliament
being established.
Even so Galloway later declared that his plan lost due to what he called the
violent party and he felt the violent party was in control of the continental
congress,
and in a sense he was right because the more radical members did have a very
slight majority and the defeat of Galloways plan actually ended up mobilizing
these more radical members because it suggested that the moderates didn't have
the power to accomplish their goals.
So with this new burst of confidence in their strength with the defeat of
Galloways plan,
these radicals proposed and passed the Suffolk resolves on October 8th,
1774 so they actually pass them
to many in Congress.
This seemed like an incredibly bold act of unity among the colonies and even
though the individual resolves we're radical,
too many,
what they noticed most of all was that it appeared to be an active unity.
In a sense it was responding to Massachusetts and to Massachusetts plight with
an action that would affect all of the colonies.
As John Adams put it this day,
convinced me that America will support Massachusetts or perish with her,
so he took it like many others as a really interesting sign of colonial unity.
Now,
of course not everybody has such a thrilled reaction to the Suffolk resolves.
One completely baffled.
Loyalist Observer said that he could only explain the acceptance of the Suffolk
resolves by assuming that the delegates quote came into this vote immediately
after drinking 32 bumpers of the Best Madeira.
Okay.
They just must have been drunk.
There's no other explanation.
This makes no sense.
Eternal explanation for all of history.
I guess they must've been drunk,
drunk or crazy.
Okay,
so clearly.
Sure.
Sign here that the colonies are not just going to be backing down
six days later on October 14th Congress approved the declaration and resolves
and they had agonized over that for a month,
so they didn't just pass it.
They actually had been pondering it all along
and the declaration and resolves actually represented.
One of the goals of this continental congress to write a clear statement of
colonial rights.
However,
this was not as easy as it might sound because America was pretty much following
an uncharted path,
never before in western history had colonies dare to rebel against the mother
country in quite this way,
so now they had to somehow put on paper a way to justify it.
Why were they doing this and as important actually in a sense,
maybe more important,
could all of the colonies agree on the specifics of colonial rights?
Could they actually even sit down and make a statement that everybody agreed on
and the difficulties that the delegates had in writing this draft really
demonstrates,
once again,
how really difficult it was to define the precise terms of the colonies problem
with the mother country,
the precise terms for the proper relationship between the colonies and the
mother country.
Even when they sat down to do it.
Okay,
you're real.
Or the committee and the con con,
the first continental Congress and we're going to form the declaration and
resolved and write down the reasons for our actions.
Even with such deliberate desire on their part,
it was difficult for them to commit this to writing.
It was difficult for them to find the right words and to agree
and the declaration and resolves was drafted by a committee.
John Adams was on the committee,
which is good because then he gets to tell us afterwards about the creation of
the declaration and resolves cause he always likes to explain his role and every
important moment of the American revolution.
So he was there.
Um,
and this,
the committee ended up basically stating in their draft that the declaration and
resolves we're going to be based on three things.
Their explanation before with what was going on in the colonies,
it was going to be based on three things.
Number one,
the laws of nature.
Number two,
the principles of the English constitution.
And number three,
the charters of the colonies.
So all of those things,
the laws of nature of the principles of the English constitution,
the charters of the colonies,
all of those things were cited as justification for what was going on,
but in a sense,
the real basis of what was coming out here in the declaration and resolves and
so in a sense what they were really most grounded on was going to be their sense
of rights as English subjects,
the power of parliament.
It was really going to be their understanding of the English constitution and
you can hear how important this particular fact was to them.
Just in looking at the list of colonial rights that they included in this
declaration as being violated.
So they,
they listed that the right of assembly was being violated,
the right of petition,
the right to be tried by a jury of their peers,
the right to be free of a standing army,
the right to choose their own assemblies.
All of these things are really basic English constitutional rights that all
these colonists were stating.
They feel they've been violated.
As John Adams later explained,
the biggest challenge in drafting the declaration was in describing what he
called quote the authority of Parliament.
What he said was,
um,
the authority of parliament was indeed the essence of the whole controversy.
Some or for a flat denial of all authority,
others for denying the power of taxation.
Only some for denying internal but admitting external taxation.
So even within this little committee,
there's only a few people on the committee.
Even there,
there are all these opinions on exactly what's supposed to be happening in the
relationship with the mother country and is,
Adam's puts it after a multitude of motions have been made,
discussed negative.
It seemed as if we should never agree upon anything.
So they,
they just can't stay with their results are.
However,
ultimately they managed to do it.
John Adams did a lot towards contributing,
um,
one particular article in this document that said parliament could not tax them,
but the colonies would cheerfully submit to bonafide regulation of external
commerce.
So we have two things,
right?
We have a self folk results,
we have the declaration and resolves.
Cottonelle congress also drafted a petition to the king and it was a restrained.
It was a respectful petition,
basically trying to inform the king of the evil plot hatching in parliament to
rob the colonies of their rights.
The petition warn the king that there were quote designing and dangerous men in
parliament and that they were trying to intervene between the king and his
faithful subjects.
Now clearly you can hear at this point the focus here is on parliament by
petitioning the king.
This congress is suggesting that the king is really still a figure who can be
reasoned with that the king is someone who they're appealing to in person to
help with a problem with parliament.
Okay.
Suffolk Resolves Declaration and resolves petitioned to the king.
The final thing that the congress did was agree on a way to secure the repeal of
all offensive parliamentary legislation and they decided to do this in the way
that they had always protested British attacks on their rights.
Surprise,
surprise,
non importation,
right?
They think that that always works on importation.
We're going back to non importation,
but this time they decided to really form a network of local non importation
committees and towns throughout the colonies to actually enforce non
importation.
They called their plan the continental association.
So clearly this is more ambitious,
at least in in the what they're suggesting it is and their desire for what they
want it to be
and as it happened before,
they included in their plan localized committees of inspection that would watch
to see who's violating the boycott,
who's drinking tea,
who's buying luxuries.
Now the creation of the continental association didn't just encourage,
not importation,
it actually had a number of other impacts on the colonies as a whole and I'm
sort of what's developing in the colonies first,
by creating the continental association and ensuring that it was going to have a
really widespread localized influence,
the continental Congress essentially created a localized government structure
that down the road would be vital in organizing the war effort and maintaining
order throughout the war.
So they're creating kind of a network just by declaring that this exists that
goes throughout the colonies.
Second.
In the process of doing that,
the association brought literally thousands of people into the war effort as
committee members.
Third,
although the continental congress was an unofficial congress that didn't have
any real authority by creating the continental association,
it basically passed a piece of legislation that applied throughout the colonies.
Committees of inspection considered themselves the enforcement agencies of the
Continental Congress,
not enforcement agencies have their local colonial legislature and in some
colonies committees actually created,
I'm sorry,
communities actually created committees of inspection on their own without even
waiting for their own colonial legislature to ask them or even for it to meet.
They just knew that this was happening and communities in and of themselves
created their own committees of inspection and then forth.
Over time as the colonies moved into war and as colonial governments really
began to falter and run into complications is the crisis really magnified.
These committees of inspection,
we're able to step into the void and assert some kind of centralized,
organized,
hopefully authority.
Okay.
So the continental association went into effect and this time more than any of
the previous attempts at non importation,
people really are beginning to realize that there's a crisis at hand.
So more people complied with non importation now than ever before and at times
before it had been successful.
But now we actually reach a new high of people complying with this.
And just one example of this,
in 1774 New York imported roughly 437,000 pounds.
Sterling worth of British goods.
Okay.
437 pounds sterling.
One year later,
1775 in New York,
this number had dropped to roughly a thousand pounds sterling.
Yeah,
that's huge,
right?
That's real compliance with non importation
and the Congress,
his final act was to agree to meet the following spring in May of 1775 if their
grievances had not been addressed by that time.
So basically they conclude by saying,
okay,
we're going to now give Britain time to hear what we've said the several months
it's going to take it to get across the ocean to England.
They can respond and take several months to communicate back with us and we'll
see what happens and if we haven't been addressed,
we will have another continental congress may of 1775
now,
as you can imagine,
the adjournment of the first Continental Congress left relations between the
colonies and the mother countries and it kind of a precarious state.
The congress and its activities also made it increasingly obvious that there
were two sides forming on the question of the Po proper workings of the imperial
system and how best to respond to the ongoing problems.
Now all along there had been people who had more sympathy towards the crown than
others.
People like Massachusetts,
governor Thomas Hutchinson,
he's now governor or like the people throughout the colonies who accepted the
position of stamp distributor.
For example,
by late 1774 and 1775 as people really began to take sides and warfare began to
seem at least possible to some people.
The people who were sympathetic to the British administration began to face some
difficult choices known at this point as the king's friends or the friends of
government,
they began to find it more and more difficult,
if not impossible to remain neutral.
Thousands of people were becoming involved in the war effort troops,
which of course in Boston they called quote military executioners cause they
have a real flair for propaganda in Boston.
Um,
troops,
whether you call them military executioners or not,
we're being sent to America in increasing numbers.
So people were beginning to take sides and those who felt loyal to the British
government had to decide on a course of action because to not declare your
loyalty to the protest in colonists was often as good as declaring your enmity
to them.
Many loyalists would soon declare with some justification that by forcing people
to sign olds like that were loyal to the Patriot cause by inspecting people's
purchases to see if they were complying with non importation that the
continental association was supposedly fighting for American liberty by curving
individual liberties.
As one loyalists wrote,
the only liberty that the Patriots wanted was the liberty quote of knocking out
any man's brains that dares presume to speak his mind freely upon the present
contest.
Okay.
These are people who are beginning to feel irked that there seems to be a
majority building in some way.
Certainly a loud group of people expressing anger and resentment and resistance,
and if you don't agree,
people are beginning to feel somewhat threatened.
Now,
traditionally,
these loyalists have often been depicted as timid or conservative men who maybe
were too afraid to side with the rebels,
maybe were afraid to fight the system or we're afraid of losing their wealth or
status.
But obviously the truth is more complex than that.
Choosing to remain loyal to the crown in the midst of a building resistant
movement was not an easy choice,
and ultimately it really required,
in some cases,
some degree of bravery because it really did put your livelihood,
your property,
and even sometimes your physical safety at risk because it potentially forced
you to put yourself on the opposing side from your friends.
Sometimes even your family.
Actually couple of,
actually a good number of years ago.
Um,
I had someone write a senior essay with me and he found a diary,
um,
from roughly this period of a person whose family he was from New England.
I don't remember where he was from.
Uh,
his family divided over what to do and half of the family felt like they wanted
to remain loyal to the crown and half didn't.
And the diaries really fascinating.
It's just shows this person trying to figure out what to do and no matter what
he does,
actually members of his family are going to cut him off.
And it really is a good senior essay if I do say so myself.
Um,
but it also was really a fascinating diary because it just really showed one
family being just torn apart by increasingly,
um,
passionate political ideas.
But equally important by just having to take a stand in a community that's
swaying one way or another.
And you can see what I'm talking about.
Actually it's another diary in this one I have a quote from as opposed to the
random senior essay I'm remembering from years past.
There's a diary of a fellow named Samuel Kerwin.
Um,
he,
he did not describe himself as a loyalist.
He does.
Stripe described himself as a quote moderate man,
and I'm going to come back to that,
to that loyalists and moderate are not always the same thing,
but he described himself as a moderate man and he said that until 1775 he lived
in Massachusetts,
obviously by 70,
75,
it would be difficult to be in moderate man.
Uh,
and in 1775,
after Lexington and Concord,
Kerwin became actually fearful for his life and that radical colony.
So as he put it,
I left my late peaceful home in my 60th year.
So He's been living there for 60 years in search of personal security and those
rights,
which by the laws of God,
I ought to have enjoyed undisturbed there.
So he's a moderate,
he feels actually threatened in Massachusetts and he decides he needs to move.
So he heads to Philadelphia hoping as he put it,
defined an asylum amongst Quakers and Dutchman.
So he's actually seeking out a population of people who maybe aren't going to be
as radical as the people he's coming from.
And he says in his diary that when he arrived in Philadelphia,
a friend came to meet his boat at the dock and this friend's opening opening
remarks.
So the first thing that the friend said to him was,
we will protect you though you're a Tori.
And this guy said it embarrassed me.
Not a little.
Okay.
So he,
he basically feels like,
and he says this at one point,
he feels like he has the mark of chain no matter where he goes,
people are sort of like,
oh,
you're a Tory,
are you?
Well,
we'll,
we'll protect you because we like you.
And he said,
he found it very difficult to find a place to stay,
to find a boarding house in Philadelphia because people just refuse to take him
in as he put it.
So many refused as made it fearful whether like Cain,
I had not a discouraging mark upon me or a strong feature of Toryism like some,
somehow people were looking at me and saying,
I look like a Tori.
Like how was it that they weren't giving me any place to stay?
So that's one person's diary,
but again,
it shows you how this person felt threatened.
And then this person even having moved to feel safer,
ends up in Philadelphia and still feels as though he certainly outside of the
majority and not having an easy time of it,
even among his friends.
So clearly choosing to remain loyal to the crown or even like Kerwin,
just choosing to be moderate in your principles could be a really difficult
choice with some pretty serious consequences.
Now,
there were many reasons why one might choose to remain loyal to the crown or to
be moderate.
And in a way just sort of using the term loyalist and throwing it around doesn't
do the complexity of this justice because there were any number of reasons why
you might not want to go along with colonial resistance.
Some people maybe were really aggressively loyal to the crown.
Maybe that was where their actions were coming from.
Maybe some people just were not excited about the idea of independence and war
and maybe that would have been their breaking point.
Some like the Quakers may have been just trying to remain neutral or pacifist,
which as you've just heard,
it could be a difficult thing to do.
And some probably like this Kerwin might've just wanted to be aloof from the
whole matter and again,
did not find that very easy to do after the war.
Dr. Benjamin Rush,
who as you'll hear in this little quote,
was obviously supportive of colonial resistance,
explained that to him there had been four different kinds of Tories during the
revolution.
Okay.
This is Russia's category of Tories quote.
There were furious Tories who had recourse to violence and even to arms there
were writing and talking Tory's,
which I always think it's opposed to the illiterate mute Tories
and obviously he's saying the ones who are really loud.
Okay.
But still,
so there,
there are furious stories.
Writing and talking Tory's silent,
but busy Tories who are disseminating Tory pamphlets and newspapers and
circulating intelligence.
And then number four,
peaceable unconscientious Tories who patiently submitted to the measures of the
governing powers and who showed nearly equal kindness to the distress of both
parties during the war.
This Russia's way of looking at things and clearly that's his own little
eccentric point of view.
But let's talk for a minute here,
but what,
what we're talking about in the way of numbers as far as how many loyalists are
there,
what are we talking about roughly percentage wise?
Historians estimate that roughly 15 to 20% of white males were loyalists by the
wars.
And,
and in this sense,
when I'm using the word loyalist here,
I'm actually meaning people who did something overt to support the crown during
the revolution,
like signing the dresses,
bearing arms against the continental troops,
doing business with the British army seeking military protection from the
British army or going into exile.
So just people who are doing those activities,
15 to 20% of white males.
When you add to that percentage,
those who just wanted to avoid involving themselves in the struggle,
you end up with roughly half of the white male colonists not falling into the
category of Patriot or if you use a term that the loyalist would have used
rebel.
So all in all,
only about half of the white male population actively supported colonial
resistance.
And at different times of the war,
depending on the immediate circumstances,
obviously people changed their views.
Now there were any number of reasons to stay loyal to the crown.
And I'm guessing certainly if I hadn't studied this time period,
I would assume that that there's like the stereotypical image of the Tori who
one would assume is the sort of aristocratic person that's really rich person
and very fancy wig with very fancy clothes taking snuff and doing a variety of
other aristocratic 18th century gentry kind of things.
Who sort of sneering at the rebels?
I think.
I think there's sort of some stereotype we have in our brain about who Tories
are.
Um,
but as a matter of fact,
they were,
the sun Doerries fit into that category.
But certainly not all.
Um,
wealth and poverty,
high status and low every kind of ethnicity could be found on both sides of the
crisis and from colony to colony.
Different kinds of people chose different sides depending on regional
circumstances.
So for example,
in New York,
a lot of the landed gentry tended to be loyalist in Virginia,
the landed gentry tended to not be loyalist in Massachusetts,
small farmers tended to be patriots.
In New York and North Carolina,
the,
or at least the upcountry of North Carolina,
small farmers did not necessarily tend to be patriot.
So it obviously varies region by reading region depending on local
circumstances.
In general terms.
In very general terms,
you could say that loyalism was stronger in the middle states than in New
England and stronger in the lower south than in the upper south.
And very strong,
particularly in New York,
which the British ended up holding throughout most of the war and weakest in
Massachusetts,
Virginia and Connecticut,
Connecticut stood up.
Um,
but there's a reason for that because those are among the oldest colonies with a
very long tradition of self government,
of aggressive self-government
scholars who have studied loyalists have noted that there seem to be several
types of people who ended up being more likely to become loyalists.
One likely loyalists,
and this won't be surprising,
would have been people who were connected with the British government by some
kind of an official appointment or were related to somebody who had an official
royal appointment for these people.
Remaining loyal was not necessarily due to self interested reasons,
although certainly self-interest could have played a part,
but as important loyal office holders are people related to them had closer
contact with the British government than most others and that they were better
able to see the logic of politics in England.
So they had more reason to be skeptical of claims about a conspiracy afoot in
England to destroy colonial rights.
For example,
Thomas Hutchinson up in Massachusetts was honestly baffled by the accusation
that there was a plot against colonial liberties and that somehow he was part of
it.
He knew that he personally wasn't conspiring against the colonies,
so he wasn't quite sure what people are talking about.
And because of that he had good reason to doubt the enterprise of what was going
on.
So that's one potential loyalist.
A second kind of person who tended to become a loyalist was again,
logically enough people who were in a religious or cultural minority and who
thus already felt a little defensive and not necessarily trusting in the whim of
the majority or the whim of angry resistant majority.
And I'm going to go into this more detail in a future lecture,
but for logical reasons,
a good many African American slaves ended up becoming loyalist for good reason,
having to do with the chance of earning their freedom.
So that's a second kind.
A third kind of loyalist consisted of people who lived out in the hinterlands,
in the back country,
away from the eastern seaboard.
And this is for a couple of reasons,
but one of the main ones is if you think about it,
the main vehicle or one of the main vehicles for radical ideas would have been
newspapers and newspapers largely circulated in large port cities.
And I've quoted already a number of times from the Boston cause that which would
have been hard to get out in the hinterlands somewhere.
Um,
Tory's called the Boston cause that that's where Samuel Adams wrote a lot of his
things is called the Boston Gazette,
the weekly Dung barge.
I think everybody just winds here and the propaganda game,
like equally impressive on all sides and the Prophet Gad,
again,
people out in the frontier in Virginia or the Carolinas who didn't have a lot of
access to newspapers might have been harder to convince of a great plot against
their liberties.
As one historian wrote,
not having been exposed to the disease,
how could they catch it?
None of these people had a particular reason to be swept up in the resistance
movement and they had reasons to resist it by 1774.
All of these people,
royal office holders,
cultural or religious minorities,
people living out on the frontier,
we're conscious minorities,
people who felt either weak or threatened,
particularly considering raging events in cities along the seaboard.
So in a way you could say that many loyalists were simply more afraid of the
rebelling colonies than they were of the crown.
Almost all of them had interests that they felt needed protection from a raging
American majority.
Now these loyalists did not necessarily have vast ideological differences from
people who came to be known as the American patriots,
but they might have.
And in fact,
some loyalists actually believed precisely what the rebels believed in reverse.
So in the same way that the colonists thought there was this plot forming and
parliament to curb colonial liberties,
some loyalists saw a plot forming among radical colonists who were falsely
claiming to represent the people.
Right.
That makes perfect sense.
Many of these loyalists did not part with the colonial majority until well into
the imperial crisis.
And for many as we'll see,
it's not until independence becomes probable and when real actual separation
from the mother country is at hand that they felt compelled to declare their
loyalty to the crown and actually break away.
This was actually part of the agony of the revolution.
The fact that many people just weren't sure what they should do.
They weren't sure how they felt about the crisis.
They weren't sure what side to take.
They weren't sure that they wanted to take a side.
They weren't sure what would happen if they did and on all sides.
People still cared about the,
they just had different visions about the right course of action and people had
to just make these sorts of decisions about their loyalties on an individual
level and obviously there were many different levels of loyalty to the British
government.
So I suppose what I'm saying here,
I'll wrap it up here.
In a sense,
it's really easy to analyze and pass judgment on the decision to become a
loyalist,
but I think it's just as easy to analyze and pass judgment on the decision to
resist the crown.
I think one way or another people were evaluating what was happening.
People were thinking about what they thought the proper course of action should
be,
and then making individual choices for any number of reasons.
Some of them ideological,
some of them personal having to do with your family,
having to do with your livelihood,
having to do with your safety and security.
So one way or another,
making this decision was kind of an extreme act.
And the period that we're now at in this course,
1774 70 75 is precisely when those sorts of decisions have to be made.
We'll be talking about common sense on Thursday,
which does a lot towards pushing some people into making a pretty radical
decision.
I will see you on Thursday.
Those of you who did not turn in your papers turned that into your up.